as for  the countries that are taking unfriendly  steps towards us towards us towards  economy  they are  asking their own citizens to dress up  warm  and to  tighten their belts  um  saying  about the  that the reason that their conditions  are deteriorating is because they are  posing sanctions on us  so this is a quite a strange situation  we are fulfilling all our obligations in  terms of providing  uh supplying energy resources we talked  about this couple of days ago everything  completely  in  full volume  we are whatever we are supposed to  supply we're supplying and they're  saying that they're closing the import  of  russian oil the prices are high the  inflation is unprecedentedly  high has reached the  historical highs  the results of their own mistakes they  are trying to blame on us this is an  obvious thing for our experts  they are just  covering up their decisions  in order to to deceive their own  population